I am a grumpy poi spinning today but I'm
gonna make the video anyway today I want
to talk about something a little more
technical on an intermediate beginning
get into advanced level and this is the
fact that anytime you're doing - and
once regardless of what 2 and 1 it is
and that includes things like a Mercedes
is actually a two and one two and one
simply means that in the time it takes
one of the ploys to go around your hand
once the other play goes around its hand
twice so classic way to start something
like this one - whenever you're doing a
tune one you're always doing a hybrid of
same time and split them because if you
look at this move when my hands are both
down the poi are both touching the
ground together the poi point down from
the hands at the same time so that's
same time opposites but when I do this
notice that when my right poi hand is up
and the poi is touching the ceiling the
left boy is touching the ground boom
because the right push going down up
down up down up and the left boys going
down down down down but on the same
rhythm so that means if I freeze at the
bottom of the pattern I'm in same time
opposites but if I freeze the top of the
pattern I'm in split time opposites
split time same time split time same
time
time split time same time same thing
goes if you do something simple like
this but in that moment my right boy
searching my ceiling my left is falling
towards the ground so I'm in split time
back the same time split time same time
split time same times the time same time
same time same time same time same time
split time same time split time same
time all of this continues to be true
with more complex moves like the trike
triquetra Mercedes but notice in the
Mercedes in that moment of both my hands
point up both poi are pointing up as
well bad news at the very top of the
pattern I'm actually in San pack split
time at the bottom same time at the top
[Music]
absolutely time same times but time same
time time same time you can find many
examples of that and it leads to all
kinds of cool ways to transition between
your modes
snick was your porting from Leviathan
grumpily you probably noticed Fabio has
been hacking my social media accounts
again Yvonne it's it's own patreon
campaign so I'm gonna keep promoting
mine my patreon campaign is patreon.com
slash net closing you can go there you
get perks food gets behind the scenes I
will end video now I have to make them
short because I'm having needed this
year's
[Music]